hello welcome to another episode of
banger week broom week what every school
I'm Gavin this is hashtag down the man
he's having away all the time look at it
yeah excellent yes we got remnants of
all the other days like this orange
juice in the milk paint paint dick guy
alright let go yeah childhood absolutely
let's all the house good yeah Oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] box
alright so my Lego skills aren't really
what they were well we had limited
amounts of good Lego most in Mega Bloks
so I reckon to bacchus we get flying
easy to get to the moon Oh ready yeah
yeah oh oh bloody ell oh good you put on
with the pop of the thing what man
these bags do not piss about
actually break the Lego up and did I get
let's just say fill out one of his
novels her on well we film that 2500
frames a second which is a hundred times
slower than it happened so quick I was
still ready fast it was pointless yeah
this is blob the whole thing like I'm
annoyed now
oh look at this crap
how are you class up it's gonna be Lego
in this class for generations this can
be noticed
Lego go but it's Tony Robinson's gonna
be a one day to get it a lot but time to
yeah well I've come Oh still some Lego
in the air Oh feel much happy now that
Lego actually went everywhere and we can
see it yeah it was good
alright there's another video for you go
on tomorrow check back tomorrow I'm
Gavin free you're Daniel Gruchy on
Twitter give it a follow yeah tomorrow
we blow the world curve the world this
is